[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
clearly
what's going on guys uh
we i am switching stuff over go and talk
real quick hustle let me make sure they
can hear you
hello ladies and gentlemen you should be
out here
we do have a um a guest i don't know if
he's going to show up because i think
there is a
a confusion on time frame because he is
on the west coast and i said 4 30. i
need to remember myself to inform some
of these people that yo we are on the
east coast we ain't about that that west
coast stuff so he might show up during
the podcast
uh
it is what it is you know if can't get
if he doesn't show up today you know
we'll get him another time uh you know
travis is a good dude i liked him i
actually really wanted him on because i
feel like travis will be a good mixture
with us you know what i'm saying
but you know at the end of the day uh if
it's something that he's got to be able
to do and you know something might have
changed
you know he he does work for ign so
i'd assume things could change at any
moment with him
and i tried it again but i don't know
maybe i have to restart obs i don't know
but you know we we still here though we
still going to get this show on the on
the go man regardless what happens
the show must go on
uh as you can tell i do have like this
genki chair i don't know what happened
but my chair broke like the little part
right here
broke
so i have to replace this whole bottom
piece
uh so i'm in this genki chair that's
uncomfortable thank god i only have to
do one try i hope to god i don't have to
do iop at this like it's been set for
but you guys know how that is
it takes a minute i don't know how long
it's going to take before it actually
gets here uh people were commenting on
this on on iop talking about my uh my
hero cup you know i like this i might go
get another one there's actually um
a dragon ball super cup with goku and
ultra instinct so i might i might do
that man i might do that but appreciate
it for coming through it's the attic
show where we talk about the past
present and future of gaming i got my
co-host with me hustle and motivate
what's going on hustle
oh man not too much not too much i uh i
mean i look i know you saw it at it but
for the people in the chat hey i just
did like a video so i'm kind of coming
back to youtube slowly but surely did a
video about seven things that we need to
see in teenage mutant ninja turtles
shredders revenge so y'all get a minute
y'all go check that out after the
podcast of course outside of that i'm
doing well man i'm just
losing my mind i'm playing um
i'm getting ready to play games five for
the first time uh campaign mode as you
know i got like 130 hours in that
campaign and it kind of will lead us
into a topic that we will discuss a
little bit later in the show how about
yourself man doing pretty good man uh
i've actually been playing um pretty
sure i could talk i mean
the review comes out tomorrow
i don't know maybe i should read the
embargo i don't know i think you should
um
i'm playing
yeah i'm playing there will be a review
coming tomorrow on this channel
um
i think i'm allowed to tell you guys
because it is on the vr if you if you
follow me on twitter i think you could
tell what the game is uh we we actually
had the developers on a couple weeks ago
so you know that that's a pretty good
pretty good thing see i can't even this
chair don't even latch here like it
makes it come back
so
it's unfortunate man it's unfortunate
but i appreciate it for coming through
man you know we already got 27 likes 72
people and you hit that like button if
you guys don't mind it helps to get to
the algorithm uh you know podcasts be
struggling man the thing about podcast
is we don't have weekly videos on this
channel for the most part so
to get the algorithm is almost
impossible but when you guys hit that
like button it really does help man it
sure helps
uh so we got a bunch of stuff to talk
about we're gonna talk about the
expectations of xbox in 2022
uh we did see uh did you see the
meltdown this morning on xbox live gold
that turned out to be a completely
overreach um what the 120 dollar thing
yeah so that turned out to blow up in
people's face uh then we got playstation
by more than there's a lot of rumors out
there going around the playstation
buying this playstation buying that you
guys know how i am when it comes to
talking about acquisitions for those of
you that says it's dead subject people
need to stop talking about it my youtube
algorithm says different you know the
best videos i have on youtube also have
to do with studios being bought by
someone else
that's the best videos i have
so people want to see it man i fell for
that and um yeah jim ryan we'll get to
that too we'll get to that i i like that
topic though i don't got an issue with
that
and then we got the unreal engine 5
showcase you know i don't know did you
see the little showcase thing where they
show uh coalition what what certain
games look like in next-gen hardware
apparently crystal dynamics is making a
new tomb raider
um you know
it's kind of crazy the do the
change in direction
that the unreal engine 5 is going like
how many games even you see people like
the witcher changing uh cd project right
changing their uh engine to the uh cyber
uh not cyberpunk 2005. so it's kind of
interesting you know we got obviously if
i see something unique in the chatter
you guys super chat we'll talk about
whatever you guys want to talk about to
a point obviously i try to keep the show
hour and a half to two hours i never
like going past two hours unless it's
something like drastic we might go over
two hours but we rarely do but anyway
hustle what do you want to tackle first
man you want to talk about i want to say
the xbox one for last in case uh you
know travis pops in but you know what do
you want to talk about between
playstation and unreal engine 5
well since i just installed gears 5
let's let's talk about that on the
engine real uh on and you know i'm real
engine 5 pardon me words are hard
sometimes you know my bad so what i
didn't know you know i'm glad you sent
me this information beforehand
this this is the same engine that they
use for the uh matrix for that matrix
demo that had just came out i think it
came out in december or something like
that or was it january i'm not sure but
it came out
late last year earlier this year
to join like a movie so i i kind of sat
through it i couldn't watch the whole
thing because i was at work but they
said it was like a billion triangles and
they can make everything like
photorealistic and they literally i
don't know how they
phrased this or how they framed it
really but it's like you can have like a
quick action like
a quick time cut scene like during you
know you could have like it's like a
quick action type thing during the
cutscene i said we already got that but
the way that it looked like that matrix
thing like
i'm upset that i missed it i know
slow-mo played it i think saul had
played it too i'm not sure
yeah
did you look crazy on stream i'm like it
looked like a movie it looks cool but
i'm done with let's make stuff look more
cool let's
make i i'm more interested these days in
game play engines and features in the
engine such as like the nemesis engine
i want to see more stuff like that i'm
tired of let's make stuff look prettier
let's make fire look more realistic like
i want to see ai
overhaul in general i want to see ai's
be able to
you know pick up like you know what
annoys me when you play like a stealth
game and they see you they look for you
for a couple seconds and if you like get
away for a certain amount of time they
just stop aggro completely they go back
to their normal routes and i'm like so i
guess you guys think i'm dead
like i guess you guys think that i just
left like like you scared me so much i
just bolted and ran like that's what i
want to see improve on and i get it that
that's going to take time but it's just
like
how much more time do we have to keep
giving because it feels like
graphics just keep improving but nothing
else around it it's like the foundations
growing on a house like we go to third
floor fifth story house but nothing in
the house looks nice like oh no
said we got a nice house but the house
got roaches all right daddy hang on hang
on let me let me ask you something let
me ask you something
well i feel like the reason why you see
what you said let me answer that
question first is because the market
dictates that right the first thing that
any of us see i'm going to say this to
the first thing that any of us see
oh damn pretty graphics same thing with
like naughty dog i get it
it's easier to sell graphics than
gameplay mechanics but my thing is
thousands my thing is
can we try to at least get both
like to a point like i honestly feel
like shadow war and shadow mordor look
they look good games
like sure they might not have been the
greatest looking games but i don't think
by any means they were horrible looking
games you know
cat daddy said beautiful trap house
facts
i just i just prefer
to have like you know and i was really
annoyed the fact that
um wb
they copyrighted
they put a copyright and um a trademark
on on the nemesis engine and how it
functions and i'm just like
stuff like that annoys me because stuff
like that prevents us from going forward
like it's like they showed up behind
closed doors and just snapped their
finger and froze that whole rail
when you know let's say microsoft would
have been able to incorporate some form
of nemesis engine to where you know uh
during halo infinite it worked their way
up with the grunts and and the chiefs
like and then that weird hitman system
they had going on there with the target
system that could have been actually
good
um so i mean i i feel that but eric you
know it has his pros and cons
i'll say it's not even really a con for
me but like one of the pros if i created
the nemesis system right is like you've
got to pay me to use it like i created
something like i literally created
something and i understand that we see
the benefits of having something like
open source like like an unreal engine
right we see what the benefits are
because we see like studios like the
coalition for example um the people who
made a valve they use that too a lot of
different you know other studios use it
too but like when i see get when i see a
gears 5 it makes me hype for a gear 6
because gears 5 looks looked amazing
even the multiplayer like even the
multiplayer and that it actually got me
um it got me back on the mission i
mentioned that earlier it got me back on
a mission to uh reinstall gears and i'm
actually going to play the um the single
player campaign for the very first time
because i had played half busters and
and that giant was looking everything
was looking official man i'm not going
to hold you it was looking official so
i i look forward to to see what type of
innovative stuff they can do with it but
i know you said you want the ai stuff
hey trust me man me too because like
yeah it's been times the way i've
stealth i was i think i was playing um
uncharted i stealth and then got away
and i got a trophy for that too i still
got away and came back and got a whole
trophy before but yeah it's just like
they just forget that you're there like
oh we we heard something but we ain't
hitting that and i guess yeah it was
probably nothing and maybe it was the
win but now i feel like though i feel
that
the interesting part is let me go ahead
and
bring this
over here now for those of you that's
seeing this you know
feel free to uh right along there uh
also i'll send a link to you in the chat
this is the studios to my knowledge
that's using
unreal engine five now i'm not saying
that
this is going to be like the end-all
be-all because obviously we know people
are going to be changing this this list
uh but
what's really cool about this uh let me
go ahead and uh send you
send you this
yeah i'm watching it on screen too
hustle okay so what what i like about it
is you know look at all the studios that
are using this you know you got
supernova i don't know who those are do
you know who supernova is
no sir i have no clue i i have no clue
sadly then we got
exile which is interesting because they
made wasteland three
uh ninja theory so that's two microsoft
studios
three microsoft studios
four microsoft studios five microsoft
studios i'm sitting in over here right i
think i already counted okay let's let's
do it again okay all right one microsoft
studio there you go
two undead labs i didn't know they were
making that under the lips
um
so we got two so far
three
four
i think
i mean there's clearly more for
five
all right so it looks like six so we got
seven microsoft studios because
coalition obviously is uh working on it
too oh seven double fine uh i there's
just so many on there man yeah double
fines right here so i mean we got a lot
of microsoft studios used in the unreal
engine five which is interesting
how many playstation ones um
um haven haven studios is the one that
foot with jay raymond so we i guess yeah
we got this vr studio
um
remedy why remedy's not theirs but they
they it seems like they've been doing a
lot of work with them but i think remedy
actually has a job with people now
okay
they have a job with um
what that uh that that asian company uh
tencent yeah what's interesting is that
right here so it's like two studios
making unreal engine five just two
and then one of them is vr now obviously
sony could buy some of these that's in
here somewhere uh but what's interesting
is i honestly feel like under engine 5
is going to be like the one of the next
key pillars in gaming you know what i'm
saying
and
for sure it's it's kind of
it's kind of crazy to see so many
studios
jump on it from microsoft
you know a coalition understandable but
then you got like cd projekt red
switching to it so
i'm just interested to see if
sony's tools and
engines are going to upgrade
to the standpoint that unreal engine 5
is if that makes sense because unreal
engine 5 is a very strong
tool and i think one of the reasons so
many people pick it too is it's easier
to
naturally gravitate with your talent
with everyone else when you come from
unreal engine 5 to unreal engine 5 and
not necessarily come from anything after
that so you know if you work on like
custom engines and then you go to that
so it's a little bit different for that
so you know that's the biggest thing
that i really got going for when it
comes to that but you know
what do you think
is
do you think that might help microsoft
because i do think that
loki
mid-generation like 2024 2025 i think
you're gonna start seeing a lot of games
from microsoft
look really really
like detailed because so many studios
are going with unreal engine five and
i'm not saying that
god of war's next game make it a look
good i'm not saying that you know uh
what's
um what's the engine that horizon uses
um
um the best
i'm not saying that went crazy i'm not
saying that's not gonna look good
but all i'm saying is are those
are those engines gonna be upgraded to
the capacity that looks like unreal
engine 5 is
and if they don't upgrade those engines
to that to that fullest are we going to
start seeing a little bit more of a
difference in
because one thing that sony's always had
is they've always had the nicer looking
games by far
but i think that as long as the
developers do they supposed to do their
job you might see a little bit more of
that of that you know scale come to to
the middle a little bit more uh we got a
five dollar super trap from don otaku
they didn't even add arcane and
compulsive are also using unreal engine
5 so that's two more students 11 studios
are using unreal engine 5.
it's it's it's insane
well eric let me answer your question
first well before i answer that question
um breaking news yeah uh remedy they're
remaking uh max payne one into yeah i
just saw that
yeah so that was the thing and they're
all using unreal engine five
yep another one who's using that engine
um
as far as uh will will playstations uh
engines evolve
yeah
the decimal engine ain't nothing to be
played with and that'll be trifled with
anyway and um
as we know gorilla they got they had
help from uh kojima with them stranded
um because they let them use their
engine kojima uh yeah kojima had found
out some new things and then they passed
it back on
et cetera et cetera so those injuries
those engines in my opinion will get
stronger now that naughty dog engine you
play last of us too right if you saw how
long
the naughty dog engine apparently yeah i
know jacket put me on game about it but
it's not a dog that they got their own
engine yep
so those things are just going to grow
in time anyway and i was
there was a rumor like three or four
months ago i i think you remember that
sony was looking to buy epic
and yeah i was saying because i made it
a big deal i was like if they buy epic
that's going to be a devastating blow to
microsoft and people's like oh no it
won't like if sony buys them and
restricts the access that certain
developers and certain publishers have
with the unreal engine 5
and unreal engine in general
like imagine microsoft just losing the
engine
that they've been using for years
like
that would be devastating like i don't
even
that would be more significant
to buy active uh to buy epic and make
them lose probably the biggest tool that
developers have right now which is the
unreal engine five then it would be to
buy activision to take call of duty
that's my opinion
well adam let me let me disagree with
that um if they weren't let's because
that was a rumor that was kind of flying
around if they did buy epic they
wouldn't restrict anybody from using
their engine actually it would kind of
be like what we were talking about
earlier in regards to um
oh my god the studio just slipped my
mind um with the nemesis system it would
be something like that they're probably
just like nah you can use it you just
gotta pay that's all they probably just
they're just charging they'll be like a
little hefty fee but like this is open
source like yo i didn't notice but when
i first got on steam i didn't know that
you could get that engine for absolutely
free you can get it for absolutely
nothing like that and download the joint
it's not about whether or not a studio
would do that it's about
let's okay let's put it this way you
know
most likely they would never do that
because they want to make money
and i'm pretty sure
that
microsoft and sony would work together
in some kind of middle ground to use the
unreal engine but if sony bought them
they have every right to make that
decision and regardless what people seem
to think that is a decision that might
happen maybe not a whole maybe not a
hundred percent could happen but if it
were to happen
it would be a devastating blow to
microsoft
imagine like i don't think they could
stop the games that are currently being
used for unreal like they would still
make the next uh um the next gears
because it's probably being made now but
after that
microsoft would have to come up with
another solution and please by all means
tell me other solutions that is just as
effective as the unreal engine five and
i know that we got the slip space engine
the forza engine the id engine but we
cannot act like those are more diverse
than unreal engine
yeah we not go that that respect to the
people who respect the 343 because but
that slip space engine man like if
nah and i get why you you had to make a
your own engine i get why you want to do
that
but no no no no it's not like certain
things on a certain level and yeah we
saw my gears earlier listen man you talk
about the masters of the unreal engine
and that ain't me talking that's digital
foundry talking you know because i know
y'all like john littleman and ledbetter
and the rest of those guys over there
man but
yeah
that's that would be that's that's
crippling like that's like a crippling
thing and it's i but i still i still
think it's extremely dope like what i
saw from that whole presentation though
addict because i never i never saw like
the the matrix thing like i saw bits and
pieces of it but i never like sat down
and watched it
and then during that video what they
also show um they had like a multiplayer
thing that was already like ready
readily available it was like hey if you
want to make your own multiplayer we
just put it in we got three different
stages they they spoke on like
difference with the sunlight um when
when the sun shines in the shadows
moving different places and if you want
to like do uh a multiplayer map at night
you can do it at night but you can have
uh it's like a
purplish
orb that's like brought blowing on the
inside and the walls were these were
white walls so the walls would change
the to the color of what the orb is that
that joint was dope man i'm not even
like i'm not no no tech head like that
but it was just like sitting back
watching that type of thing i just can't
wait to see what what all the companies
do with them um especially haven since
uh and then i'm not making this a fanboy
thing but jim ryan and the playstation
brought haven off the rip and that's the
engine that they're using i can't see
now i can't wait to see what what
they're coming up with because if they
bought them immediately and that's what
they're using and for the information
that i gathered today like i think it's
going to be uh quite an amazing
technical feature
so i said people in the chat are bugging
man yeah first off i i looked it up like
epic is worth like 17 or 20 billion
dollars
don't think that sony if they wanted to
they couldn't get that money
you know sure they might have to
you know put out some loans
uh you know
probably borrow money from people like
tencent or something i don't know if
they mess with tinsel like that but i'm
pretty confident that if sony wanted to
they could get that money now it's not
as easy as microsoft microsoft they just
got to convince a few people to spend
some money that they already that's just
sitting there enough doing nothing
but when it comes to sony if they wanted
to
i think they could easily get that now
sure maybe it won't be a clean buy maybe
they would have to like merge with epic
or something like but i if they wanted
to they could get that money and that's
all i'm going to really state on that
you know
speaking of playstation we'll go ahead
and talk about it man we'll talk about
there's rumors everywhere man
playstation fan but let me set up let me
set up
playstation fanboys have been bugging
here recently and i'm not you know
apparently um
people are moving days of their podcast
you know i think greg miller did it uh
they're moving it here they're moving it
there
i
because apparently last week
all week every day it was every day
sony's buying a new publisher uh one day
i think it was from software uh now we
could a little talk a little bit about
that i don't know if we talked about it
last week but we could talk a little bit
about that um they were supposed to buy
um uh konami not uh and then and then
capcom and then i'm just thinking
wow like it's like i said a minute ago
they could buy these companies like
people need to stop having just because
you're not as rich as microsoft doesn't
mean you can't afford stuff like that
you could easily do it and with the
relationships they have with these
companies they could probably have a
better chance at buying some of these
companies than a company
like microsoft because microsoft is an
american company and i'm sure there's a
lot of friction when it goes to the
microsoft and some companies over in
japan uh so it's
it's
it's kind of i know cat daddy i think i
think the
the go-to when it comes to buying a
company is that you want to buy them
what they're worth and then you want to
add what they would make in 10 years i
think that's the way it was described to
me
like you know if they make 17 billion
dollars and they average like 2 billion
a year or something like that you would
give them an extra like 10 to 15 billion
on top of that uh but i don't know how
that goes i'm not gonna assume that just
like you guys are assuming sony wouldn't
do something like restricting access to
uh unreal engine five like it kind of
besides bungie sony
has no problem doing stuff like that now
it you can argue that they would do that
because it is an argument and i would
say there is a good chance they wouldn't
restrict access to something like the
unreal engine 5. but all i'm saying is
and if this is theoretical because the
whole damn scenario is theoretical first
off if they were to do something like
that i would think it would be
devastating to microsoft because they
would have to find new outlets to make
their games that's besides the point i'm
not going to read the chat anymore all
right but you know when we come to the
playstation
out of those studios who you think would
be the best purchase for microsoft out
of um out of from software capcom
and konami and i think square enix was
one of them too i don't know i don't
know which days it was every day was a
new studio that's supposed to be vine
yeah well i'm gonna well hold on capcom
but i'll get back to that capcom is the
best you said for microsoft to buy no
for the playstation to buy oh
capcom hands down uh mazda hunter i'll
just join doing numbers but i do want to
say this um
shout out to greg miller this ain't no
slanted cuz you you know but sometimes
you got to hold your l um he had a
little gift and he was i think he was
pounding the desk or something he said
i'm gonna push that ball push back the
podcast ps4 p.s i love you or whatever
starts to push you back to like thursday
because stuff might be happening
and i'm like all right well what the
hell might be happening then it was it
wasn't just him it was other people too
so i'm just looking around and i think
that might have been more of oh craig
miller did it i'ma do it too you know
what i'm saying like yeah
i i guess i guess and you know again you
know greg if you you're more than
welcome to come on if you want to greg
you know but
yeah now sometimes you got to hold that
l but that that was just more of a thing
to where it was like i think a lot of
times and i'm not
you know i think a lot of times people
hear stuff
and maybe
i feel like this is most streaming for
something else jim ryan had came out on
i think it was one of the playstation
podcasts i can't remember which one but
i saw that in the article earlier the
way he was like yeah we bought um you
know five studios in 2021 and we got two
this year in 2022 we gonna make some
more acquisitions so when a lot of
people was just running around saying no
you know they're gonna do this they're
gonna do that
i don't know listen i don't know where
from software came from but if from
software is on that list boy the price
of the brick went up
the price to that brick went up
and not to mention it
capcom would be mad expensive like
it would be
a very huge process for for a company
like sony to get the funds they would
need to buy these big massive publishers
like i don't think people realize how
much money
really they
that they have like look they have a lot
of money but when it comes to something
like that they have to really
they have to really i wouldn't say penny
pinch but it's something like you have
to convince the board that you want to
spend this kind of money and when it
comes to microsoft like i've said
multiple times in the past it's easier
to convince a company and the board
members to spend money that's just
sitting there
devaluing in in
in cost too like you know the the cost
of the dollar keeps going down it's easy
to convince people to do that than it is
to convince people that you know
this might
bankrupt your company if it goes
sideways
or at the very least put them in a bad
situation
so it's it's interesting for that now
i'm on the the side that i think that
sony doesn't need square enix i know
people are in the chat saying uh you
know square enix would be a good buy and
i can understand where you're coming
from that
i actually if they were to buy any of
these i think capcom would be the best
per choice because i feel like
they would put a
kind of a
a wall up on the of the fighting
community they would get street fighter
now obviously there's still because bam
namco makes a lot of head dead fighters
and i'm hoping they're making the next
killer instinct because there's a lot of
rumors going around about that but it
would be interesting like
i'm just curious how much money
sony's willing to put out
like and people keep forgetting like you
know they try to buy the company that
the the parent company to
what's that company called uh that that
game called war uh warframe they tried
to buy that company and
they were in the bidding for that they
were in the bidding for wb games
uh and we're talking deals it's in the
billions not the millions in the
billions
with a b
and they were trying that hardcore but
it's like you know when you're in these
kind of bidding rooms you're in the with
google you're in this bidding rooms with
microsoft obviously the person selling
can pull out as well like
if they don't come up with something
they want they're clearly going to pull
back themselves so i honestly feel like
capcom would work the best for sony
because you're you're cornering a market
that you don't really have now you have
it to a point because you own like evo
you'll get monster hunter
square enix is going to put games on my
uh on the on the playstation platform
regardless if they go multiply for the
majority of their games i don't think
you have to mess with that but when you
look over here you get street fighter
you will get the hunter uh the monster
hunter franchise you'll get a lot of
stuff and i think capcom makes resident
evil like imagine if resident evil went
multiplayer you know would be crazy i
know this would never happen
i know this would never happen but once
that they bought capcom
and they let naughty dog make the next
resident evil
hey
no i honestly feel like naughty dog
would make an amazing resident evil
i mean you know it's
and it's just that too um yeah capcom is
the most like desire we'll pick uh we
didn't mention konami whatsoever like we
didn't meant to konami whatsoever
because who wants kunami i don't
understand that like i said i saw a
float around i was like yo why them like
of all people like i get you got some
ips over there like castlevania like i
get if you want that ip cool but
that nah nah and then like and for the
record y'all they don't make uh they
don't own ninja turtles no more um
because i would i probably would have
said that i'm a big turtles fan but no
they don't own ninja turtles people uh
nickelodeon does so it's not
that's not konami konami's making the
the remix and stuff but that's in
conjunction with nickelodeon by the way
it's because nickelodeon owns them so
now so konami is up out of there um
about that running the best the ones
that you picked for that job
because you pretty much got the king of
the fighters uh there ain't no pun
intended by the way but you got the king
of the fighters in street fight that's
it it's the pinnacle in a lot of
people's minds so
now you got them and if i'm playstation
them the ones you make a play for hey
attic i don't know if you remember
2012.
capcom almost went bankrupt they almost
they did
you know what's crazy
the the
180 that that company has done in the
past few years you got to respect the
man like i'm not the biggest fan of a
lot of capcom games now i like resident
evil i'm a fan of realizing franchise
the resident evil lore i've played them
all i'm actually one of those people
that feel like all resident evils are
good even six is an okay game it's not
an amazing game it's definitely one of
the worst resident evil games but i
don't think resident evil 6 is dog like
it's horrible i just think it's one of
the things that
maybe they should have focused on one of
the stories and not five individuals or
four however many was there but it's
just like look like
i think monster hunter is a pretty good
franchise i think they would do well for
that now i know obviously nintendo
they're probably out there looking for
stuff too um
cat daddy you could buy konami for forty
dollars and some applebee's coupons okay
dad you got some applebee's coupons yo
hit me up without joking look it's just
like
i get so frustrated with people
it's just like
i don't understand why people find
konami so valuable
like i unders
ips are good but clearly the company's
not doing anything with those ips ever
we've seen over and over again they if
there's the one thing that konami knows
what how to do
is drop the ball
and it's just like i wanna i just wanna
see
their ips be used like i know a lot of
people don't like this game
uh but i don't know why it was
castlevania curse of darkness it was
it was a game that was about the uh
about the people that worked with
with dracula yeah they called them
innocent devils
like i really enjoyed that game and you
know actually you know the castlevania
tv show on netflix right now
i haven't seen it yet but i don't know
well the main charac one of the
characters on there is named hector he
he uh
he's pretty much he controls innocent
devils he's the main character
on
uh
castlevania curse of darkness like he's
literally plays him
and
you know it's it's just interesting that
look i'm not saying that they're not a
bad student i'm just saying in terms of
gaming now
the studio is isn't what it is like
they're their ip's probably worth more
than konami
yeah
yeah and i mean but that's that's the
thing like when you
when you get that you get that for game
preservation to say i mean you could buy
and have
have a nutty dog you could have a
gorilla you could have whoever work on
the next castlevania if you want to or
like you can but you would you would buy
them for that purpose but like that's
the least desirable one out the of the
crew on that one um
especially when they did they just
release their games like i said if
you're not gonna make nothing if you
won't make anything a new one you just
solely want it for the remakes to
remaster you you kind of just you let
that stay away set you let konami just
do what they do so
yeah no no but but capcom is that's
that's the the front runner as far as
i'm concerned cause like i said monster
hunter i didn't notice but apparently
that's their best-selling franchise
yeah monster does really good who owns
mega man is that capcom
yes
yeah i think mega man needs something uh
who on sonic uh
uh sega on sonic
yes yeah i've always personally felt
like when it comes to xbox i'm more
competitive i want xbox to buy sega
because i feel like that would that
would close a lot of loopholes when it
comes to sega uh when it comes to
microsoft uh and then you know you could
theoretically the sky's the limit you
could
you could spin off the sega into
xbox japan
like
sega is in charge of xbox japan i mean
there's so much stuff you could do with
that uh you know if they if they don't
get sega i think score enix would be the
best
studio for publisher for microsoft to
buy uh if they bought set they bought
square enix which i don't know if the
screens would ever sell to microsoft
but imagine if they bought square enix
they effectively
took away every bullet in playstation's
gun like yeah but well at that point
yeah um
if if it ever does come down to it we
can speak on the second thing for a
minute if it ever does come down to it
then it means you'll have persona they
want like
not even just persona i i was playing um
superman said though
last week when i was playing a game that
you may not have heard of but i was
playing a game called super widget which
is made by atlas
which is
uh you know i just dated myself but that
that's that's fine atlas has been around
for so long and you do have a lot of
history with that organization so
there's there's a lot that you can like
draw from that um
i would be focused on making like new
stuff if you know because oh my god
microsoft has the studios now they got
the studios now so
you know they can give me that up and
just saying with playstation you know
they got studios now do they want to you
know bring something back they can bring
something back um i tell you this but
you know and i don't want to develop too
much
what microsoft does need they need their
own version of a bluepoint studios
they do they got a lot of
stuff that i feel like they could really
um
use
for when it comes to that
yup i mean it's just
i don't know it's just it seemed like
that's like the next step for for
microsoft because it seemed like they
got everything else together so
that this is what it is this is my
opinion i do think
i do think games like resident evil 2 3
final fantasy 7 remake i do think that
they re
did
the term remake i don't think you can
get away with doing remakes unless it's
on that level anymore like now i feel
like if you do something and it's not to
that degree your your stuff is a
remaster it's not a remake i don't care
what you did like if you don't
thoroughly remake a game you'll [ __ ] to
remaster
like in my mind
no no i was gonna say no no capcom
definitely raised the ball when it came
to that because like i said we was just
talking earlier they was on the brink of
uh
extinction for lack of a better term
they were like afraid like it was it's
about to be over and then they came
you know they came searching back so
i don't know man i i think if i'm no but
if i'm playstation you get capcom i want
to drill that point home you that's what
you get if you don't get nobody else no
at no other time that's what you get i
don't think that they need a studio like
blue point but i do think that that
they got so many studios i feel like
they can they can make their own games
now but like sony has that studio to do
exactly what that studio does but i
think when you got 30 plus studios and
including activision obviously it could
go through it's not that but when you
have that many studios i feel like you
don't need a studio like blue point
because you always have at least one to
two studios that once they finish that
project that you could present them with
that okay do you want to do this do you
want to do that i think that's the
reason you don't really have to go into
that and you know you could easily i
think me personally i feel like it would
be an amazing idea if you start
co-developing games between the
microsoft studios if you start having
like um
obsidian and bethesda co co-develop a
game
like sure you don't even have to have
the main studios like you know how they
all like to say the b-team a team
start having b teams work with each
other
yeah how about that because i feel like
two b teams working with each other
might make a better t game than the a
teams of both those studios
i i'll be willing to put some money that
they won't be able to but um who is that
luke skywalker yo your name is crazy um
you said you want to see diablo or
diablo style go to next and listen they
tried to remake golden next um i don't
know if y'all saw it but there was a
demo this playable demo out called
golden axed which you know they kind of
made fun of themselves for um for
canceling the game it's it's like a
three-minute demo i think it's it's not
even one level i think this is part of a
level um
yo people don't want gold next no more
man and i'm the retro cat around this
joint but people don't want golden eggs
that's all what i'm sorry servant that's
all yeah you know we've completely went
off subject a little but that's okay
because uh this is kind of dry week
anyway what what would be like your
dream okay i'm not gonna take old games
because i don't really know too much
like you cognito king you guys know that
old scene more than i do but what would
your dream studios remaking some of your
favorite games be
oh okay in a dream scenario i do want to
see
i do well we're going to see perfect dog
being remade but let's say that um but
let's say um
the initiative wasn't making um worth
making that game for me
a perfect dark remake made by the
coalition in terms of the third person
uh studio then so i'm gonna give
playstation that credit too
for me
once again
golden now
made by naughty dog would be like my
playstation like equivalent to that kind
of the same game but not really
yes but you would turn it in the third
person naughty dog i know for a fact
would have more of a narrative like lead
for a golden eye game which would be
dope it'll probably be their own
original story but you know you know you
know i know the dog get down and the
mess is a storyteller um the coalition i
i trust i will trust them enough for
like fun gameplay regardless of what
people may think about their stories or
whatever
that that game play and they know how to
push a female character to the forefront
and then how to make it dope um like
they did with kds so i would trust both
of those studios with both of those two
franchises how about you sir how about
you
um
i would want
i think i think
um what's that company called the one
that just made psychonauts i always
forget their name um
double fine i would like double fine to
be made by
i think they would make a perfect
banjo-kazooie
i would like for them to make
banjo-kazooie i actually thought dead
space would be a somewhat remake dead
space i've said it a couple times on iop
but i would like dead space to be me be
made by ninja theory
because dead space is more about like
the mental
struggles of isaac
like especially two and three like and
three he's literally having full-blown
episodes and i feel like
that would be a really good thing to go
for because
you could see
ninja theory knows how to make that type
of game
uh we got a one a two dollar super chat
from
jc
carmario i you know butchered it we're
gonna move right past that ff 9 remake
my dream i i think isn't that one of the
one of the
leaks that happened that they're making
at ff9 one of those amd leaks or
something travis is on his way right now
um
yeah i think uh and to be honest with
you you know we'll stay on this talk
because i don't know if travis wants to
talk about the unreal engine thing we
might revisit that briefly but you know
i honestly feel like they
they could make that now final fantasy 9
the question i have to you in the chat
anyone that wants to you know uh
gravitate towards this question is do
you want them to go like a final fantasy
vii type of way or do you want them to
stay in that same kind of turn base
or that turn based scenario with that
they that they did in final fantasy now
because i feel like nine had a very good
turn-based structure
and
seven to two but i feel like nine had a
really unique one as well so i'm kind of
curious if you guys want them to keep
that kind of uh mentality or not uh
definitely put in the chat there but you
know what any other studios you can
think of any other games
oh um
yeah you know what but i've always said
this too when this question kind of
comes up
i'll say naughty dog again but i want
them to remake uh metroid
yeah super metroid yup
no metroid prime there we go i want
something with a story that's royal
prime i think i think nobody dog could
do that they'll make it third person or
whatever but i want them to do that
um yeah if we just if we really just
running around here picking um ain't
nobody else gonna rock with this one but
i'm gonna say it anyway um
animaniacs had the game on super
nintendo was one of my favorite games
you know
i i i want um
who who's the dude who just made kirby
but um sakurai i want his studio
i'd like for his studio to remake
animatics and the maniacs was a game
that was made by um konami for the
record and um you know one last one man
um wait which i just had it i got that
it just went away you know that's fine
that's fine but i kind of want like i
want some of the older stuff to come
back and um
attic i don't know if you know this
and the maniacs was won the hell of a
game though you it might be it might be
before your time look i'm gonna hit you
with a download a lot of the things you
talk about before my time fam i know but
you got to go back to it
this is a fun game man this is back when
um super nintendo and sega genesis had
like two different complete versions of
games because mode seven was the thing
and that um something that sega didn't
have um
our processing like the eye processor
whatever that was called it was
something that super nintendo didn't
have so they had to make two games this
was third-party companies making the
same game they had to make two different
versions of it
oh boy yo people to lose their mind if
that happened today
i i just want to say for the record
people will lose their mind if they
happen today turtles in town is another
one that really comes to mind they had
different they had whole different
levels in their attic
same game
you know well not without the same game
but like same franchises right
completely different level so yeah but
that's
i know that's just some of the some of
the ones that i won't know to go if you
make a lot of stuff by the way i think
that they dope i think that they'll give
sam naughty dog doesn't have to remake
everything remember the blitz football
game
yeah yeah i was just playing yeah blitz
football i remember playing that for
like the n64 i'm not even a football
dude but that that was that was that was
pretty fun i will say bluepoint does a
really good job at remaking
old assets to their original but
bringing it forward to a lot of people i
think they did a good job with demons
they did a good job with um
what's the game with what the colossals
and stuff uh
um
um
shadow of the club shout out the classes
yeah i think they do a good job with
stuff like that uh but you know
we could talk about machine games real
quick
what have they been doing
you know maybe we should keep that for
when travis gets here when we talk about
xbox but i'm very curious what what
they've been doing it's just like when
it comes to these studios man like you
know just just make good games like i i
don't understand why people
get confused when a studio doesn't like
sell well
you know we've been covering the
industry for this long
we can pretty much tell you what games
aren't going to sell
like it's kind of it's kind of crazy how
much
we can really see
like the the
the drift in some of these games i'm not
saying these games are bad
but i am saying that it's like one of
those things where it's like
you look at the game you look at a game
on youtube you look at some gameplay on
youtube and you know feel free to answer
in the chat too like when you see this
i for one
yeah that game's going to do bad like
that game's not going to do well like
it's just like and if we can see it the
consumer how do some of these developers
can't see it
maybe they can see it but i mean it
could be a mario maybe they're in a
tunnel vision they've been working on it
so long
that very well could be yeah but you
know it could be a myriad of reasons
like you know a lot of things could
happen due to budget constraints it's
like a real thing like your funding
probably could get cut it was like hey
how are you supposed to have this
animation that's supposed to be here
and that gag hasn't got no money like it
could be one of those things i mean it
could be turmoil in the office it could
be a ton of
things yeah this is the most this is the
most set up i like this setup man
i don't know
why i right now i i haven't macked out
until he gets ready but you know
i do enjoy
things that go on i i personally
just want to see more when it comes to
like playground making fable i think
we're how many years into fable like we
need to see some of that too
uh but you know travis getting ready you
guys uh you know keep in mind uh you
know what what i what i like about
travis's setup is i like those uh
those destiny posters on the back man
that's what i thought oh right you got
the little yoda set up
well look
looking getting the lighting right and
everything got a two dollar stream trap
from dollar talker remember everyone
said
uh game of the gall was gonna be bad
uh
wait what's g-o-t-g i don't i don't know
game of
you got to tell me what you mean by that
does anyone know what those initials are
i wonder if i could google those with
those initials show up
someone someone google that tell me
guardians of the galaxy now look look
when it comes to guarding the galaxy
there was a lot of reasons why people
thought that game wasn't going to do
well
so i i could understand
the criticism for that game
that game isn't game plan so anything at
it yeah now it is
yeah so i mean
i hate it's pretty good i might as well
go ahead and test that out speaking of
game pass while we you know
we await our travis's unravel here um
i don't know whether to thank you in
that but i've been playing um
what's that
the outer worlds thank you for that like
oh you like it
yeah it's cool yeah i just got i got a
provided yeah so we about to go tear
stuff up the way that we tear stuff up
so
your template looks a little off okay
king that's uh we're waiting on our
travis to come in so we can uh include a
map
yeah yeah the template's fine i'm just
waiting for him to pop up i'm gonna
switch everything over man
hello king
this is this this is
i appreciate you guys being so patient
with me man i appreciate it the video is
behind your pictures
uh really
no i i don't see it
well i'm looking at i said i'm looking
at this live we all right well look i
mean it's just a black screen but
what's going on uh travis
oh he's still he's still he's still
messing with stuff man okay here can you
can you yeah we could see you now um
hey youtube
so so this is where we were travis
uh because i kind of figured when we
started the podcast i think i think we
messed up the time zones i think we
messed up
yeah the times pm and we didn't talk
about
i was like i i was actually free it too
if i would have known i could have i
could have hopped on but yeah i totally
forgot your east coast so i just didn't
even yeah
uh you know
this is the superior coast by the way oh
man okay
we we don't do that you know we we don't
we we don't contribute to the west coast
times you know we assume that you guys
automatically gonna think
my time okay because that's that's that
that that's that's the chosen time i
mean if we're gonna go off of like gdp i
think like maybe you guys should come to
our time i don't know they said you're a
little low travis
oh am i i can fix that
and uh as you're getting that together
travis the only thing that i enjoy about
west coast time in particular is the
fact that you guys can watch this
game releases you guys can watch the
super bowl at the time and still be able
to go out and if you want to go out you
can go do that like
i will admit you guys got a lot of uh
nice little perks for that for that
three hour difference i i lived on the
game in the games industry it's nice
because all the servers are here so yeah
they said you're still a little low
really okay yeah
how's that
it'll try to turn up just a little bit
more
hello
yeah you're starting to sound better
i'll turn up uh the the audio just a
little bit too
uh so okay what we was talking about
travis uh is what he was talking about i
missed like an hour right oh no you're
fine you're fine the only thing you
missed is talk about the unreal engine 5
showcase so i think
i think you you you dodged a bullet
there a little bit
uh so we're talking about playstation
you know all these uh quote-unquote
rumors that's going on travis with them
buying this and buying that i don't
really want to talk about this uh you
know the rumors themselves because i
think some of them now i'm not saying
that sony isn't looking at some of these
studios but i'm saying that sony's not
buying all these studios like you know
from what i've been told goes behind
closed doors is these these companies
are always talking always like all year
long they're like yo you know they're
trying to pull up yo would you sell that
for this would you sell for that but you
know most the time nothing ever goes
through so you know i don't know if you
kept up because uh you know i know you
you work a lot over there so let's talk
about
they were supposedly going to buy i
think on a monday they were going to buy
from software on a tuesday they was
going to buy capcom and on wednesday
they was going to buy uh konami and on a
thursday they were going to buy as a
square enix now out of all these studios
travis what do you think would
what
what's wrong i'm looking for what shift
up the industry the most is sony bought
one of those studios
that's a good question so i guess my um
take on acquisitions is
uh obviously i don't think acquisitions
are particularly good for the consumer
most times
but if if an acquisition is going to
happen i would like it to be
a
studio that's been around for a long
time and is sort of on its
at what i would consider an acquisition
stage where it's kind of stopped
innovating and now it's sort of time to
go right like to me the the activision
acquisition is perfect because that
company was bloated and it was dealing
with problems from
below with its own employees and it was
dealing with problems from above from
california suing it and all of that
stuff um so am i still low really yeah
they say i turned you up all the way too
yeah i'm pretty high over here they said
you talking soft
[ __ ] stuff yeah it's a difference
we'll we'll hear you just fine because i
can hear you just fine now but um for
youtube i guess zoom and youtube don't
really play nice together in terms of
audio so you might have to turn um turn
yourself up just a little bit
stand by all righty appreciate you
yeah i get what you're saying like
what you're saying is
acquisitions don't make sense until
there is a point where the studios
aren't doing what they should be doing
naturally so maybe someone needs to take
over to help push that innovation along
like it's it's like it's like you know
if somebody buys your studio
then probably all the people with like
ambition are going to go and work for
they're going to leave and start their
own studio again i mean they said they
can hear you fine now all right perfect
yeah um so that's sort of the um like
their mo right and so
um to me like i don't know i don't know
if we talked about this uh addict but
like i was devastated by the bungie
acquisitions yeah because i i honestly
think bungie got acquired at the wrong
time they were finally independent they
were growing as a studio they're making
all these innovations and then what's
the worst thing that could happen to you
at that point in the studio or in a
studio life cycle is you can get
acquired by a large company that is
probably going to cause some kind of
brain drain because
you know playstation's plan is basically
with that studio we're going to use
bungie's knowledge on games as a service
to help us reach our goal of making 10
games as a service games in the next
five years or whatever it was they said
and uh that means that there's fewer
people working on destiny and there's
probably going to be people leaving who
don't want to be a part of a large
organization and want to do their own
thing and so especially coming from the
activision thing that they might for
sure there might be a lot of people that
still feel away yeah and they've never
worked well with authority to begin with
they didn't work out with xbox
activision was tough so i just i don't
see it really working for them
and that sort of acquisition hurts me
when i see a like studio in its prime or
like where it's way too early like haven
that was a really weird acquisition by
by playstation where like they haven't
even produced a game and you're like why
why did you buy the studio just seems at
the wrong the wrong time to do it so i
was told something i don't know you know
i gotta ask you is this what really did
you really say
buying haven is like it's like
pre-ordering okay
i did say that oh my god oh my god
that's a good job if you if you think
about it they're kind of pre-ordering
the studio they saw a really nice
trailer of what the game could be but
they haven't actually produced any games
they don't have a working relationship
together so it's sort of like they just
pre-ordered a studio more or less that
hasn't actually produced anything so i
stand by that honestly i i think that
was a really odd acquisition in mind it
is it kind of feels like
they're not maybe necessarily worried
that people might buy the studio
they're worried that if the studio takes
off after its first game then maybe the
the price like like like also likes to
say the price of the brick going up so
sure i i would argue that that it's
worth the increased cost if you get to
vet them for a while you know what i
mean because because it's not like it's
not it's not like they're not going to
make money off of that first game like
playstation would make a ton of money by
being their partner and their publisher
on that first game and then if it makes
sense you finalize the deal so i i guess
what i'm trying to get to is there's
certain studios i wouldn't mind sony
acquiring and there's certain ones where
i personally would be pretty devastated
and one of them is from software like to
me
you don't sell your company when you're
like leading the pack in innovation and
you're sort of like from software could
could stand to become
you know a large uh powerful uh
publisher slash developer and i i would
hate to see them get acquired at the
time where they're like
hot off the heels of elden ring and
things are going great like i to me you
kind of have to wait until
they've settled and they are now sort of
like a super established kind of like
the old guard that's what the companies
where i'm like okay they should get
acquired like it makes sense at this
point they're not really innovating and
so to that point i think capcom probably
is a good acquisition at some point uh
konami probably at some point uh those
sorts of companies if one of those got
acquired i wouldn't really be
surprised and i don't think it would
hurt the industry really but a company
like from software i just
i i can't see them as as a
non-independent company with the way
that because you're you feel like
they're still innovating they're they're
generally yeah just the way that the way
that they exist i feel like that's not
what you sell you sell when you're at
the top of your but then again you know
from software i think they're owned by
someone aren't they
no they have a publishing agreement with
me okay so yeah i thought someone said
on twitter you know obviously i should
have looked up uh facts beside before
going along with with the twitter space
to say they do have a parent company oh
yeah that's that's what they said they
had a parent company so yeah like to me
i think one of the only aspects that you
would see is you would see a company
it's just like you know privately owned
by someone you know
some of what you saw with uh the the
person who owned minecraft
uh and mo like it's just like it's not
necessarily about where they're gonna
take the brand it's like yeah
unnecessary like i'm getting old man
i think i think it's time that i i take
i take my money
and and i ride into the sunset and i
think that might be a scenario that you
might see
with
from software selling where it's like
this it the the price of the break is
never going to be this high ever again
like
like sure we could go higher with
another game that's after elder ring but
we can also descend as well so it's just
like maybe i should sell for the most i
could ever make right now
but do you think that
miyazaki's in it for the money based off
the type of games he's played and his
narrow scope of like his vision you know
what i mean i don't really see that as
the end goal like
i just they're like yeah i don't know
they're crushing it with as as they are
right now and i feel like part of their
ability to just do so well is that they
don't they don't answer to anyone they
get to make the games that they want to
make and i um you do lose some of that
independence like
you know bungie is probably the the one
example here where like they have their
independence written into their contract
and it's probably not going to affect
them too much but even then as they say
i don't believe that i don't believe it
either because like here's the thing
like people keep telling me
bungie is the one that's that decides
things and they're the ones that get the
final thing acting like bungie
themselves isn't court that can't be
corrupted like oh you don't have to
convince all of bungie you just have to
convince the decision makers at bungie
that the way they need to and people was
like well then they'll just they'll just
cut they sold themselves to them for a
reason and i feel like look the contract
might say this
but when sony is the one funneling the
money
then you could easily arm strong people
oh you know oh you don't want to do it
i'm going to lower the the money train a
little bit like okay you got 10 billion
last year we're gonna we're gonna dial
it back to two you don't like that two
do what i say and i'll give you 10 again
like
yeah i'm not so worried about that it's
more um
it's more that i just think when you do
that you put pressure on the higher ups
and then you put pressure on the people
getting money and then the people
getting money that you know the
developers wanting raises the people
that they're trying to keep with
retention bonuses you got to keep them
happy and it's going to squiggle up the
battery and then they're going to end up
going not maybe not necessarily i do
think that the bungee thing is going to
benefit destiny
because i honestly personally feel like
maybe destiny but i don't think destiny
let's say that you know i've brought
this up travis and you know we don't
really talk a whole lot uh i listen to
you on last word and me and you
sometimes we go back and forth on what
we agree on but believe it or not we
have a lot of similar agreements so
so i personally feel like
let's say project matter i think that's
what it's called project matter that
takes off matter is the code name i
don't personally feel like
maybe there's a scenario
where if matter is so successful
they start letting the gas off a destiny
to put like if they're still independent
because they're trying to go hard in and
i don't know if they can realistically
uh if they can really simply support two
games as a service to that degree i feel
like one is going to get let off and the
other one's going to get put on more
so here here's my problem with the uh
bungee acquisition so we're in we're
since we're in the thick of it and uh
and it's sort of related to this topic
of playstation acquisitions
my problem is that i don't think it's
going to benefit destiny and the reason
i think it's not going to benefit
destiny is because if you look at sony's
messaging all their messaging is about
improving their games as a service model
and obviously since they now own destiny
part of their interest is in making
destiny good but they also have this
ambition for all these other games as a
service games that are not destiny and
they want to use bungie's brain trust
for that and their incentives to keep
people at the company aren't to keep
people at bungie it's to keep people in
sony right in playstation if you stay at
playstation you get your incentives and
so
that i i feel like there's going to be a
brain drain of people from the bungie uh
company to work on these other projects
how much you want to bet sony
low-key poaches people from their own
companies yeah i think
i think they absolutely will i think
that that was basically what they said
in their press release and then if you
look at what bungie said in the press in
that same press release you hear from
sony hey this is all about our games as
a service vision we know bungie does
this well and we want them right it was
an accu hire is basically what they did
and um
if you look at bungie's messaging it's
all we want to do movies and music and
sony has that it says nothing about
destiny really doesn't it doesn't say
like hey we're getting acquired because
we think we can make a better version of
destiny we just said it says it's it
says we sold out because we wanted to
drop a hot single on sony music that's
basically what it says i saw another
example where like i get it that they
want that that cinematic
way
but i feel like there's like 30 other
companies that could have did that
better than this company and they
probably wouldn't have needed to sell
their soul to them either like
sony
we see sony pictures they're hit and
miss
and their hits usually had marvel
influence like
yeah i i think for me it's i just think
i think they should have stayed
independent personally because
um they that was their messaging for
years after the whole activision snafu
destiny was bad for like almost two
years and during that time they were
like hey bear with us you know we're
we're going through this whole thing
where we got to get our independence
back and it's going to be tough and i
think as fans we were like all right
well this kind of sucks but we're with
you bunji and then we waited all that
time and then just when things were
getting good they they sold it and it
just it that pisses me off as somebody
who stuck with you know lesser versions
of destiny for as long as i did and now
we're we're at this point where
you know they we're just right back
where we started basically
hopefully hopefully they are
ugh
i i just think that over time that gets
eroded whether you mean to or not so
even if you are independent after a
certain number of years everybody who's
on the bungee team will start thinking
of themselves playstation and
they they kind of their them retaining
their independence
is uh contingent on them maintaining
their culture and everybody seeing
themselves as bungie employees not
playstation employees and i just don't
think that works long term long term
they start to think of themselves as
part of the playstation team
and uh that's you know i just think f
five years from now sure i think it
probably works ten years from now
i think that they maybe start making
moves that aren't really bungee moves
under more playstation moves because
after time you know
a person leaves here gets replaced here
you know and then if you're looking at a
whole different group of people who have
never thought of bungie as being
independent they just think of it as
being part of playstation and that's
really the problem is it's kind of a
slow death by a thousand cuts and plus
there's also that
you can look at it from this aspect too
um travis where
let's say project matter does mad
successful and destiny's still doing
good but it's not like meeting sony's
kind of like expectations in like five
to uh five seven years like who says
sony doesn't like look matters making us
so much money we'll just cut destiny
like
and and at that point bungie's doing
like you said bungie and sony's culture
is like so mixed together
where
there's so many people left in and came
left and came where there's only a
handful of people that's that's still
part of the original bungie crew and if
you look at it we see the same thing at
343 where it's like a lot of the essence
from halo's still there but a lot of the
core people have left there
so it's like it's like that at any
studio like people don't stay at the
same studios for two decades generally
and so this is gonna it's sort of an
inevitability it's just uh
you know you definitely lose something
when you become part of another
organization even if it says on paper
you're independent that's just not how
it works in practice and so i think sony
made out like a bandit i think it was a
really wise decision for them to buy
bungie it's a great company it
complements perfectly something that
they're very bad at which is online
service games and i i think bungie gains
very little to be honest they were
already raising money you know they
raised like a couple hundred million
dollars the year before they're building
their own campus they have all this
potential to expand and i view them as
having kind of given up
uh so that they could you know make a
destiny tv show and that to me is super
disappointing as somebody who was
hanging out with this game for as long
as as i have and you know i'll still do
it but it's just uh it makes me real
nervous and i'm really surprised to see
the reaction from the community be
um
i'm pretty much the only voice that i've
heard of who actually thinks that it was
a bad call um which is super surprising
to me as long as everything is done how
sony and bungie claim publicly i'll be
okay with it but i don't personally feel
like it's going to go down that way i
feel like there's going to be a
honeymoon phase where people are going
to keep stuff to the straight arrow kind
of like activision there's a honeymoon
phase where like they didn't want to go
too much into stuff but
once sony
once it comes down to where sony doesn't
like like there's a difference between i
don't like the way you're doing it but i
don't really care at that point
and then there's decisions where sony's
like i'm completely against we got to
see how sony handles i'm completely
against decisions
sure and that's going to be interesting
you know but you know let's
let's talk about xbox travis because i
know uh you know talked about
playstation up clearly e3 is gone
uh which you know it's kind of
interesting
how is it like
the mindset at a company like ign with
like an e3 entity gone is that like
relieving or are you guys like
how is that kind of mindset it's it's
probably mixed i mean on like a a
personal level uh the e3 events i went
to were
some of the most fun you know times i've
had with like the ign team or other
teams i've been a part of and so
i i'm gonna i miss it a ton and i i'm
gonna miss it comes back i hope it comes
back in some form just because it's such
a cool um you know piece of game history
and the whole industry's there you get
to see all these competitors and rival
publishers and game console uh
developers and all that stuff and uh all
in one place and just hanging out which
is so so cool and i think healthy for
the industry so i will miss that but on
the other hand
ign has benefited a little bit from e3
not being around because we do our own
mini like e3 event now you know oh yeah
ign does a thing called summer games and
last uh the last couple of years during
covet we sort of took a lot of the steam
off of e3 and we're like we're just
going to do our own like eat a little
mini e3 thing so i think there's some
people at ign who are like oh yeah
competition gone it's all gonna be us
now but we'll see we'll see if that
actually happens but uh i i think most
people probably are are sad that this is
going i mean there's it's good and bad
will i miss the crowds no well i miss
the all the people who didn't wear
deodorant today no but
i will miss uh i will miss you know the
the fun kind of gathering and the
parties afterward and all that stuff and
uh yeah it's it's sort of a bittersweet
for sure yeah let me get this gerald
back with the 19-month message all held
the ilp salute lord addict and hustle
and motivate in the esteemed panel
definitely appreciate that so the reason
i talked about that is you know if e3
gone i personally feel like it's gonna
be like a phoenix thing where
something's gonna originate in its place
i don't know if it's gonna be
involving the esa i think that's the
initials of them uh i don't know if um
what's his name uh people jeff jeff
keeley going to do something and take
its place i do think
people look at it from the consumers
aspect where they're like let's watch
conferences which a lot of these people
don't even look at anything on the floor
you know obviously ig uncovers it but a
lot of them just look at the the
conferences and then they just take off
you know what i'm saying so um i don't
think people realize what what e3 was
doing behind closed doors yeah it was
bringing people together like you know
these companies like activision ea well
ea not to a point where what's funny is
people want to be part of e3 that e3
height but they don't want to be part of
e3 that's why they do it the same week
so yeah
i consider e3 mainly was the celebration
of gaming in that week where everyone
even if you weren't part of the e3
floors or you weren't part of the e3 you
know conferences you were still in that
week to celebrate with your fans with
the industry and i don't think people
realize
when you have all these influencers all
these media you got ign gamespot you got
all these people in one place it is so
easy to get things done
and i don't think people realize that
industry side that developer side you
know we could push back the the consumer
side the people at home watching we
could push that back but
that has to be replaced by something i
don't think that's going away something
is going to replace that
i hope so and if even if it's something
that's 100
industry insider facing because i know
e3 in the final years was also invited
members of the public in which
kind of made it a a little bit
chaotic if you were there to conduct
business but to your point attic like
e3 wasn't just conferences that was
actually the opening of e3 after
conferences the rest of the week was
about you know we would get to see
behind closed door demos and plan our
coverage and kind of figure out which
games were going to come out this year
that were going to be hot and
interesting to keep an eye on and
there's a lot of like
good work that got done out of there
it's also just like a place like if
you're dev you probably wanted to go to
e3 so you could rub elbows with other
companies and look for like future job
opportunities and kind of see what other
games are out there and get inspired and
i to your point like
god man it just had such a important
kind of place in the industry when the
years was around now you mentioned the
esa
i think the esa was a pretty crappy
organization to be honest they were
started as like a you know trade show
organization that was uh a whole bunch
of different shareholders coming
together to sort of
uh present
their original the original uh you know
mission was to
uh present to the general public the
games industry for people who weren't a
part of it so like yeah you know in the
90s when there was that whole
uh video game violence watch your brain
thing and congress was telling the
entire world that video games had like a
terrible brand and would make you like
violent
the esa was formed to sort of counter
that as like a pr organization like hey
here's what video games are actually
about and they're super fun and you know
look at this somewhere around the line
like the message got lost
somewhere around along the line i think
it sort of just became like an og like
blood like a monster
yeah that told that you know told the
world my physical address so maybe i
have uh my own oh yeah qualms with them
but they uh i just said you were one of
the people that got leaked with that
whole thing oh yeah and people sent
death threats to my house after that so
yeah
yeah i i got i so yeah obviously i i
kind of think the esa is incompetent
just for that reason but uh i do think
that they sort of lost their way a
little bit and it's it's actually not
that video games don't need pr if you if
you actually are somebody who pays
attention to politics you'll see that
video games currently are going through
some stuff um at capitol hill um that
that probably we could use an advocacy
group for but i just think that they um
the industry sort of outgrew them and so
if there is a new uh a new e3 i hope
it'll be formed under some new
organization or something like that
because i really do i really don't think
e3 is coming back next year i think
that's a load of yeah but what i've been
told behind closed doors is like
it seemed like
esa felt like they were irreplaceable
like they like they
they would be around no matter what i
felt like
they they the key thing they had for
years is they had the ability to bring
the industry together
for that week
for those floors they had the ability to
do that but felt like they slowly
started losing that ability they lost
sony
ea
they lost nintendo to a point we eat
nintendo was still there but they
weren't there it's kind of weird how
they were they were on the floor but
they weren't like part of the like when
it come to like the conferences and
stuff i felt like once they lost that
that's when they truly lost the ability
to function and i felt like it was
arrogance to a point i felt like the
company itself felt like they were
bigger than everyone that they didn't
have to make compromises with anyone uh
letting so many people into the floors
without any compromises to the media to
influencers like
it's like you could have did something
as small as sure maybe would have
extended e3 to a point but it's like
having media and just having a date of
exclusivity you know what i'm saying but
it felt like they didn't care they
didn't have those conversations they're
like you're going to listen to me
because e3 is that place for that week
and no one's gonna take that and then
the pandemic happened it's like it
accelerated the death of that company it
was kind of already on a downward slope
did you ever go to e3 hustle no no i've
never been um
i was going to say it it kind of was on
like the decline anyway because i know
we saw nintendo nintendo was like the
first ones to like completely pull out
of e3 and i think that they were like
the pioneers well just the conference oh
yeah yeah yeah they were like the
pioneers
of that floor every year
huge part of this
so you guys would have to explain that
to me but i remember like when when e3
was going through its troubles before
sadly everybody's addresses were leaked
they were talking about bringing their
celebrities it was like like lebron
james and like having his own booth and
stuff like that i'm like yo that's not
that was the number two trying to bring
more
to the event
yeah i always also feel like it just
takes takes away but uh but you know
shout out to ign jeff kelly like you
guys have your own things going which
you know easier for me to watch like i
see when ign goes live is right there so
like
it's a cool cool thing um
nah no i've never gone to e3 and um
travis you know one of the opening
statements that you made about e3 i
wouldn't i wouldn't have made it in
there because you said people stink man
i'm not gonna be able to function i'm
not gonna be able to move around like
it's pretty bad
it was bad dude i mean the good news is
if you were pressed you got to skip
lines so you didn't have to kind of like
go through it but it was still just like
shoving through people's faces so that
you could run like half a mile across
the show floor and then get to the next
like meeting room you had to be in for
your next appointment like i would do
like 15 appointments a day
at e3 and so you're just like doing like
a 32 hour minute like uh demo and then
you you sprint to your next one and get
there like just in time it was so brutal
um but yeah
the i to your to what you said hustle
which i think is an outsider's
perspective is pretty interesting which
is
the conferences
that didn't happen like nintendo didn't
do their conference which you view as
them like pulling out of e3
are actually different than them pulling
out of e3 altogether what they did is
they just said we're not going to do a
conference yeah they're actually like
entirely they were doing direct they
were just doing directs so we're going
to go do our own like presentation but
they still bought a huge lot on e3 and
had all their games there and we're
showing them to press and developers and
fans who showed up and like they had
these massive like
theme park like mazes you could go huge
like i can't
yeah let me see if i can remember the
breath of the wild one where you had
like they basically put like hyrule in
the e3 uh like show floor and you like
walked through it and stuff so they were
still doing e3
they just decided that they weren't
going to do a press conference and they
were actually there more than anyone
else was and i was actually told
that when sony pulled out they bought a
lot of their floors too yeah so yeah
yeah yeah and that's where
sony and ea were the ones who actually
pulled out of e3 period like not only
did they not do a conference at e3 but
they didn't buy uh real estate on the
floor which i i think was
uh a tactical error in some cases just
because
you know
they sort of weren't part of that
conversation those years
i'm going to send you hustle what the
floor looked like in 2018 that was the
year before uh uh that was the last year
oh eight and 19 was the last year 18 was
the year before that uh but the crazy
part is like that's probably the reason
that i could like i got really upset
with sony like because
ea at least was a couple streets down
you know what i'm saying like they were
in the facility at you know nintendo
they're like look like we're not gonna
do a conference because we're switching
how we do things but we're still gonna
make sure our fans and the people that
enjoy our product they have something
there sony's like we gone
we ain't doing no conference we ain't
doing nothing that week we ain't having
any kind of venue around that corner we
ain't doing nothing at the e3 show floor
you see us in a couple months like and i
felt like
that was a low-key like disrespectful
like it's just like you can you can be
there in some form like microsoft was
doing the galen center to a point like
they they were still on the floor but
they were doing like press stuff in the
gaming center like what's crazy is
microsoft went out of their way more to
have more of a middle ground for press
people than the actual people who owned
e3
yeah which is weird they had like their
own like little separate
area just for the press so that they
could show the stuff that they weren't
ready to show the public yet yeah which
is something that esa probably should
have set up themselves i feel like they
should have had a fan
a fan gathering and then just like the
main e3 floor gathering
that was my actual question because both
of you went to e3 like
how did they not separate y'all from the
rest of like everybody else and also
travis i think it's it's very
disrespectful the fact that you have one
meeting here and then you have to run
down like it's like the east hall
to you know catch another meeting like
there's no other way that they could
have
like maneuvered a little bit better for
everybody else
was there's two big buildings and
there's like a little thing connecting
them and obviously there is other stuff
in other parts of the place but
you know they would literally have
travis being what because
what was worse is when you had to go to
another building
yeah it's not like a government building
it sounds like sometimes sometimes you
would have to run off of the e3 show
floor and go to like some other
you know conference area that that they
had booked separately because there
wasn't room on e3
so about like the
the building the the the stuff upstairs
well it was like you know if you went to
pc game show that was in a different
year and ubisoft did their conference in
a different theater that year and so you
had to go to like this different part of
town i had ubisoft was like a little bit
away too yeah it was like a little bit
away so that was and they also showed
some of their games in a separate
building so it just depended on you know
you structuring your day like this game
of jenga you know where you're trying to
like make everything match up and am i
gonna have enough time to get to this
appointment but that's actually fun but
to answer your question about the fans
the reason they didn't have separate um
spaces for it is because originally e3
was only for uh insiders in the industry
and gamestop employees for some reason a
lot of them came like 10 000 a year no
that i remember 10 000 a year
yeah yeah because gamestop has a lot of
employees um it was like a lot of them
but uh but then then one year they
decided okay we're going to let fans
come in but we're only going to sell 10
000 tickets and then the next year it
was like 25 000 and then it just kept
going up so i think originally it was
just hey you know we have more room on
our show floor like let's include more
people and then and then after a while
it was just like okay dude this is too
many like it's just super crowded and
there's no like place for them to turn
into
not to be elitist like oh get these
peasants out of my game conference but
it did make doing business more
difficult like it's it for sure did and
that's why i always said that
they needed to find a i'm not like not
like king david like king david's like
keep the peasants outside like yeah i
don't think that mentality was the right
like you could keep them in but you need
to have a better middle ground like
let's give the media like a certain
section of the floor maybe or let's give
the media a day excuse
there's a difference between someone
doing this for a living and someone
doing this for a hobby like they're just
there they're not even doing youtube
channels they're just there as
exhibitors they're just looking at stuff
then people have this like
weird conception to think that this is
about playing games it's not like
you are never going to play games for
the most part you might you know unless
your media media had a little bit more
uh you know hands-on with certain things
but for the most part if you came there
as an exhibitor you will play maybe one
or two games a day
for sure yeah i uh
i mean i played a little bit more i
guess like i did i did participate in
demos but that wasn't it wasn't like you
had time to enjoy it it was like all
right let me hook up my capture
equipment and you know then he was
writing pretty much the entire time
there right you know
yeah and then any if you had like a
20-minute break like ign had a separate
like war room that you'd run into and
you just like slam your laptop down on
the table and you'd like try to get a
preview or like a video posted and then
you would run back to the show floor to
do something else it was just
a constant kind of running around
situation but i actually love that and i
will miss it if it never comes back but
uh in terms of i think the the headline
here is that the esa did not really
evolve with the industry and and in the
way that i think they should have to
make e3 continue to be relevant and i
think that showed to a certain extent
which is why you saw certain pieces of
it falling off near the end and then
eventually you know now it's gone all
together so i hope it comes back i hope
it comes back better um and uh yeah i'm
gonna miss uh i'm gonna miss the hanging
out with snoop dogg and keanu reeves and
the people i got to hang out with at e3
right now i think something will come in
this place and you know for all i know
um you know i do think that
jeff keeley has a particular
advantage right now because
he does
have relations with the people that
did leave
like i think he might be able to use
that gauntlet to bring the industry back
together i just don't know if he could
do it you know what i'm saying like
there's a difference between having
relations and convincing everyone in the
room that you need to be the place to go
so i don't know if he'll be able to do
that but that's not really you know kind
of went on a side engine on e3 there my
question to you travis and hustle is
we got microsoft's coming up you know
that obviously they're gonna have their
e3 uh you know whatever they're going to
do this year that would have been in the
place of e3 what do you think realistic
expectations needs to be for this
conference or whatever they do do with
this type of event you know what we'll
go travis first what what do you
personally feel like we need to see at
this type of event
um
yeah i i think um if if the it depends
on the messaging right like uh sony i
think has decided that they're not
really going to do they're kind of
moving to the
nintendo direct model right but they do
these little small state of plays and i
think that sometimes they let the
messaging get away from them about
what's going to be included in the state
of play and then people are like oh this
is going to be an e3 press conference
and then they talk about like one game
for 20 minutes and that's it right and
then people end up disappointed so i
think messaging is everything if xbox
says hey we're going to go and do you
know a couple small events that focus on
certain types of games we're going to do
like a little first party event and then
we're going to do a an indies event and
we're going to do a third party event
then i think the expectations probably
need to be tempered but if they say like
hey in lieu of e3 here's our press
conference then i think the expectations
are rightfully gonna be really high and
i think uh microsoft has every tool in
their belt to meet those expectations
they
you know bethesda used to do their own
press conference at e3 and now they have
bethesda as part of their press
conference so that already increases the
kind of potential there extremely if
if they combine shows with bethesda they
could let bethesda do its own show i
mean there's certainly an argument to be
made there they're their own company
with a whole portfolio of their own game
so i could see that yeah i actually
heard there's like a little tr like
uh friction between the companies on you
know how they handle that going forward
so it's going to be interesting how they
do that i'm interested in like when
activision's brought in the fold if that
goes through like are they gonna let
them do their own thing like because you
know uh call of duty still a thing and
yeah even though
call of duty's huge the ability to
announce the new call of duty is is huge
by itself so are they going to let them
do their own thing are they going to
take the big stuff from both portfolios
and have one show with it like it's
interesting how they do it yeah uh
hustle what do you think what is your
expectations with it
well honestly they needed microsoft
needs to do what they did last year in
terms
of we did the live reaction it was game
pass it was like 27 of these 30 games
are in game pass they won
those things they're going to have to
hit on that level um
we've been talking for quite some time
pretty much ever since i've been here
about 2024 2025 2026 for microsoft
um they need to roll some of that stuff
out early like like a perfect doc
because we've heard things about perfect
doc and all like the the turnover rate
over there so i would like to see
something from perfect dark i would like
to see something from a val
i know you're a fable cat so i would
like to see something from fable so like
all of the newer stuff or all of the
like the 2018 announcements up until
like 2020 i like to see game play for a
lot of that stuff for me i don't
necessarily think i'll get all of that
but um
i feel like you got you got a rebound
like because the show last year was
really good
the show like they had one misstep and i
think that was
it might have been a year before one of
you one of you guys corrected me on it
but it was whenever playstation and xbox
was getting ready to drop the new
consoles playstation had that press
conference and then
microsoft had the third party conference
that wasn't that didn't go over so well
with the people this is the best subs
uniform
and so i think that's my point is like
are they going to do one big show and
basically make it a replacement to e3 or
are they going to do a few different
shows where maybe they talk about third
party and then first they're going to
name it and then activision like travis
are they going to break up the part
they're going to say xbox presents
activision conference xbox i could see
that i could see that and if they do
that i think people need to change their
expectations yeah drastically
drastically but but it's it's sort of on
microsoft to market it the right way
because if they say you know if they
just put an xbox logo and a date and no
details people are gonna be like oh [ __ ]
this is it like it's gonna be you know
star field and they're gonna announce
the new xbox series x2 and you know all
this stuff and i think they they just
need to decide what their strategy is
personally
i would love it if they united behind
one big like two hours that's what i was
about
i would love that i would love that but
i think i think the industry is actually
going the opposite way because you see
nintendo direct being successful you see
sony doing kind of a piecemeal little
state of play presentations and i could
see them breaking it apart into like i
do five presents i think
i think that's probably what they'll do
and i think if they do that everyone's
going to be disappointed because
everyone's expecting it to be you know a
blowout like e3 so
well i wanted to mention i wanted to
mention that they will more than likely
break this up in the past because travis
you know that if you know two news cycle
24 hours y'all so you know how it go
xbox would normally go first playstation
would come and then just take all the
xboxes shine on like that's that sunday
with that something they have they used
to like structure those conferences
before right
now it's more like i we got one day we
got one day we got one day yeah they'll
spread that out and um as far as but
that's the thing i don't think that they
even touched that or activision either i
think
with
not the not the initiative but like when
with those big studios publishers like
that they're gonna have them run
themselves anyway so they're probably
just business as usual in my opinion
activision didn't have its own
conference then they actually used to
put all their games into other shows
yeah they've uh
they would put call of duty and xbox
shows during the 360 era and then they
moved into playstation during ps4 so i i
feel like they either have to
give activision its own show or they're
going to have a huge section of their
presentation that's like that's gonna be
good you know what i mean because you
know what they might do travis are they
gonna talk about candy crush you know
what i mean like i feel like there's
there's enough uh
there's a there's enough uh their studio
their portfolio is so big now i mean
minecraft alone has its own conference
it has its own like e3 like event and i
feel like if they really wanted to they
could do that with a lot of their
properties just give it like their own
event but um i don't think i don't think
they're going to i think i think lord
you're completely correct they're going
gonna do like four or five small shows
and everyone's gonna complain about all
five of them because they were missing a
piece you know what i mean that's
probably what's gonna happen you know
what's a realistic thing that i just
thought they could do is
stick to what's new like what's coming
out now i kind of like to do in star
field like let's say overwatch mike
coming out this year or early next year
and and like instead of that game huh
no way we see that no but
i'm i'm just saying like next year like
i'm not saying this happening this year
like starfields this year where they're
focusing on starfield games is coming
out this year next year uh you know they
might have another conference to show
future stuff a little bit more where
it's like an xbox or like beyond thing
and then next year you you'll see
whatever's coming out that maybe i don't
think a vowel would come out that year
uh we might see something on i think
that might be a possibility where it's
like look
this year we're going to show starfield
we're going to show red fall maybe
depending if that gets pushed and then
next year they're going to show games
coming out next year in the holiday the
year before and then maybe they'll have
like
because right now i feel like
the best thing they can do is show
better outlets to their games in general
kind of like a nintendo direct something
like that and then they use these shows
to show what's coming out this year and
next year like gameplay
uh you know big
flights of stuff like i think that's
something they might do
because if you
split up an activision of bethesda
you're gonna have uh issues on is this
studio if this publisher gonna have
something they could show uh is anything
realistically able to show like we just
mentioned fact division or we go show
call of duty and and and a little bit of
overwatch like and then just call it a
day like weird i feel like it'll be yeah
it's going to be really splitting things
up could be headaches by itself but if
you go like okay this year overwatch is
ready next year like maybe it's just a
show
let's let that be one of the pillars
let's let you know maybe the outer
worlds 2 might have something to show
because i've been told they're a little
bit more developed than people think
maybe show something on that like maybe
keep it
2022 2023
up to e3 or whatever they do next year
and then next year you show the next of
next year and up to the year after that
yeah
i i think the other uh thing we haven't
talked about is the possibility of them
basically just save everything
everything for gamescom gamescom is
actually maybe x actually blowing up
maybe they actually because i've always
i don't know how you feel about this
travis i've always felt like
video game awards is one thing uh i
still think you do too much with the
video game awards because i feel like
sony when sony does an event like an
event where you know something relevant
is coming
it generates so much buzz so much hype
and i feel like microsoft gets some of
that but the reason they don't get all
of that is because microsoft will
literally show vowed
the show grounded
and then six months later or a couple
months later those show the xbox series
x and and hellblade well it's like if
you would have brought that to your own
show i feel like
like throughout the years you would
generate that type of because people
know microsoft stuff is going to be on
their stage not the video game awards
not
gamescom it will be on their stage do
you think that maybe they should start
doing that since they own so much stuff
microsoft has a stage at gamescom they
get their own conference it's just that
in the past they've always relegated
like what i would call the b news to
gamescom right like i remember one one
year they showed a whole bunch of new
stuff and then the next uh gamescom a
couple months later they showed like
crackdown three and they did like a 30
minute demo of that and so i i feel like
it always ends up being their b show so
gamescom is thriving it's still
happening it's a huge fan event they can
show activation stuff there i could see
that being kind of their new e3 home but
i do think that they need something i
think you're right like they can't just
show everything on other people's stages
they i agree that the game awards is
like not really the right setting for a
giant uh press conference or anything
like that i i don't think that they
should use it for that they have made
some really they could debut like
gameplay stuff there something little
yeah yeah or that they should because i
feel like if you're showing something
for the first time that needs to be on
your stage
yeah well they showed the new console at
game of thrones that makes sense i will
give them that that made sense because
they were coming off of a generation
that wasn't too
kind to them you need to generate as
much hype need to do stuff different
that makes sense yeah yeah i also think
that um it helps when you get outside of
your own bubble because if you're
announcing something that you think is
going to appeal to not just people who
care about xbox then that's when you do
it at the game awards because if you do
your own show at the microsoft theater
and it's called a microsoft presents
event only people who care about xbox
are going to be watching it but if you
showed at the game awards playstation
people will see it nintendo people will
see it and i think that's a pretty big
deal if you're trying to expand your
user base which they obviously are in
this game pass era
so yeah i i would be interested to see
that there's lots of different ways they
could approach this um i guess we'll
just see who's who's going to make the
first move at this point we we're still
waiting for one of these guys to
announce sort of an e3
review announced something before so you
have to imagine that they knew e3 was
going to be canceled a long time ago
yeah like because i was getting whispers
months ago so there's no way that these
companies didn't know it'll be
interesting that now you bring it up
travis
like
that would be very effective for
microsoft they to have people like
companies like ign gamestop like always
writing about them gamestop they
announced the next call of duty they
announced uh you know next year they
announced overwatch they maybe announced
a vowed game play like this year they
they show starfield for the first time
and people this isn't that much time
between each other let's say they buy
something like sega in the future or
something kind of like a japanese outlet
tokyo game show they're showing their
games there like
then they do their own exo then they do
the video game awards they show
something they like that's consistent
coverage all year long
yeah
give you plenty of stuff to write about
travis plenty of stuff to write exactly
which is what i mean
yeah so how do you feel um hustle how
how do you how would you let let's break
this down a little bit how would you
want them to handle it for your personal
preference and how do you think they're
going to handle it
like as far as their their coverage
uh you know what
travis you might hate me for i mean look
if they cover
one conference over the next five or you
know one conference per day over the
next five days because i mentioned this
earlier like the news cycle is 24 hours
like i can't i can't make a video about
something on wednesday or something that
happened monday yeah people might go to
it but
it won't hit the same if i do it the
same day right so they'll probably have
everything split up um as far as having
everything in other places travis you
have brought up the point earlier
microsoft has to appeal us to different
audiences this is why we see like the
xbox series x premiered at the game
awards same thing with hellblade because
everybody from everywhere is watching
the one big thing out the year it's like
the soup there it's kind of it's like
turning yourself into like the super
bowl of gaming too so
no no if i'm if i'm microsoft maybe just
you know take your time no no not like
jeff kelly type of time because if
someone gets somewhere in games never
ended that year that he did it but not
just take your time and say hey we're
going to start june what 10th to june
15th and just have it like that and and
everything would kind of work itself out
so
yeah yeah but i i really don't have no
like no better ideas but like as far as
like i know you talked about xo i
wouldn't prevent nothing that exo man
because xbox fans are they already got
y'all they already got y'all if you're
xbox fan i already got you for exo so
you i wouldn't even like take it there
everything else though like it's in
gamescom that's out in germany correct
did you guys correct me on that one
jeremy yeah that's the one that holds
like 500 000 people
it's huge and it's because it is a fan
event it's not like you three
i mean well i would say this then
there are certain things that are
booking me out there and at the game
awards as opposed to just having it on
like the exo stage wherever they choose
to have it like it was you're talking
about xbox celebration right xbox
celebration yes yes yes i would i would
prefer to have things in the bigger
venue yeah you have something for your
fans but
i i'm putting my my stuff on the biggest
venue possible
that's biggest i think and i think that
was the one strength of the esa is that
it created the biggest venue possible
for all players and so it gave everybody
a chance to show their stuff in front of
the widest audience possible and i feel
like now if everybody goes and does
their own small little thing it'll end
up making everybody speak to only their
own echo chambers so it's like the xbox
people will know what's going on with
xbox playstation will know what's going
on with sony but like the average gamer
who just logs on once a year to e3 just
to see what's going on in general and
doesn't really care about one console or
publisher over another they won't really
have a place to learn about all the news
that year and and that i think is
troubling which you know i have hope
that ign game fest will be that place
right that would be awesome for us if we
could uh we could
create the largest stage uh using our uh
our huge audience but i just i
personally don't see that
happening sorry ign but i just don't
think that uh
i think it's really hard to create a
coalition um
that involves like all the companies
because some people the usa probably
naturally had it because it was they
were so old in the industry and people
and they were they were made up of
people in the industry so the esa was
actually made up of like all the biggest
publisher and developer stakeholders so
like phil had a spot on the board and so
many people were on the board
at some point they're like
it's like it's like you know what ea was
on the board they just didn't buy stage
space if i correct me if i'm wrong
someone but i'm pretty sure that they
were still a part of the esa until the
end they just were like we're part of
the esa but also rebel rebel we're doing
our own thing on e3 so yeah i mean it is
what it is you know people in the chat
are coming after me saying that i'm
flip-flopping on my look i'm not saying
i i still want
microsoft to consistently because i feel
like there's a realm where inside xbox
and a nintendo direct both can exist
especially of how much they own like
people don't realize the amount of
content that xbox owns now like it is
absurd
you can't realistically show all that in
a couple events like you have to have a
lot of them that's why i feel like
inside xbox structured restructured
don't bring it exactly how it was where
they use that to outlet to show ninja
like ninja theory gameplay to show fable
gameplay and they use the nintendo
direct to show you know game pass
announcements uh indie games that come
out you know and then they show uh
japanese games coming to the platform
they could use that for that then they
use the shows
you know the the exos their their own
conference to show the big content uh
but obviously
like you guys said they need to be
everywhere but the problem is with being
everywhere is you're not building your
own platform to show where you need to
be when sony does an event sure there
might be more world
accepted but we can all agree when sony
does an event everyone's covering it it
doesn't matter who it is everyone feels
like they have to be part of this event
now i'm not saying microsoft could never
be there part of the reason sony's there
is because they've already did their
footwork and i felt like microsoft was
attempting to do their footwork but the
xbox one generation put them back a
couple notches where they had to
restructure in some areas
right
but you know i appreciate everyone
coming through man you know you know we
we could talk a little bit uh travis you
know i'm sure that you've seen the the
unroll engine showcase stuff was there
anything that stood out to you
no i mean unreal engines a hell of a
hell of an engine i i i'm impressed by
everything i've seen except for i still
haven't seen a game made in it so uh
excited for that what what game was it
that announced that they were going to
be the first one to publish in unreal
five oh you know what it was it was the
matrix
yeah i didn't i wasn't really impressed
with that i wasn't impressed yeah well i
was impressed by certain aspects of it
but you could tell that the people who
made it were people who knew a lot about
the engine and not a lot about game
development which is kind of how i feel
about people who work at epic in general
like whenever you see a demo
i don't know
that's just if you if you see the the
demos that they make it's like okay
you're really good at showcasing stuff i
got into a little debate with the chat i
don't know how you feel about this but
uh because i remember a couple months
ago there was rumors that sony was
trying to talk to epic about buying them
and um and i was saying that
you know i think it's too big epics are
too big but i was saying that if sony
was able to achieve that
and
obviously
people in the chat confused what i was
saying i never said that mike sony would
ever do this but if if sony's able to
achieve buying something like epic
and just started playing hardball with
the unreal engine i don't realize i
don't think people realize how much
power sony would have with that engine
like for sure we could never buy it
though huh
they could never buy it i feel like they
could if they if they if they if they
100
was
the entire company of sony was behind
trying to buy epic i feel like they they
could come up with that money
i
i'm gonna i'm gonna fact check you here
okay fact check me because i feel like
every one of those scenarios where it
would be it would be a huge bet but i
feel like they could even if they
because the playstation name is a very
profitable name i don't think that they
couldn't they could they could
easily they could get those loans
yeah uh
so uh epic is worth
28.7 billion dollars
and sony is worth 128. that's tough dude
that's what i'm saying like i'm not
saying that they would buy that i'm
saying that it's like one of those
things where
it would be a hard sell because it's not
like something microsoft microsoft could
buy that and if it would flop or it
wouldn't do as well it would it would
annoy people and they would probably be
a lot of upset people but microsoft
would eventually level out sony would
make that kind of commitment i don't
know if they could bounce back from it
very easily if it didn't go the way
here's the thing just looking at that as
a as a proposal
if epic
got bought by sony i feel like the loser
would be epic because sony would gain a
really cool tool set
they would have lots of new customers
using uh their engine it's very
ubiquitous uh engine
like the vast majority of companies use
it if they can afford it but what would
for sure happen is sony owning it would
mean that other leaders in the space
would have to emerge because there would
be people who don't want to build on
epic if it's owned
nintendo would would abandon it if not
that they use it really for any of their
projects but they would a lot of
microsoft uses that engine microsoft
uses it and microsoft would not use it
anymore and you think you think you
don't think that they would try to work
something out with them i i don't think
so because they already just acquired
their own engine when they bought
bethesda
yeah but and it's and it's a damn good
engine it's a good engine but i've been
told by a lot of developers that like
it's not as diverse as something like
unknown of course it's not of course
it's not but you think microsoft would
see the long game as they often do and
they have the war chest for it which is
invest in your own engine we can build
our own thing and just make that the new
epic and
uh
or or there would be a third party which
i think is probably more likely a third
party would probably just to hop in and
go okay well now that epic is owned by
playstation there's this new market of
people who probably would prefer to use
another i do think that i i think there
would be plenty of opportunity to do
that so i just think epic would never
want to sell because they like the fact
that they're being made they're making
money at all all customers they're uh
somebody would have to come with them
with such a big bag that they could
probably want like i think yeah like if
if because
if epic here's what here's the reason i
don't think they can afford them if
epic's current valuation is 28 billion
you're buying it as sony you have to pay
a premium on top of that because you
have to pay more than the company's
worth in order for it to be sold so
let's call it like 40 billion and then
on top of that you have to if you're the
epic people you're trying to think out
all right well if if my business now is
going to be based on
only selling to sony and probably losing
a lot of business with microsoft then
you have to build that extra cost into
that so you're looking at like a 50
billion dollar acquisition would be my
guess and that's like half of sony's
worth yeah you don't acquire a company
they don't have enough they don't have
enough liquids
they would have to take out loans like
yeah imagine if they jumped out the
building like that and the industry re
like
didn't react the way they thought it
would like like microsoft was like yeah
because they would have to probably like
coalition would probably finish out
making like gear six with that like i
feel like there would be enough time
between these games being developed
where microsoft could have some form of
answer to the unreal engine like they
don't have to use it anymore but it
would be i would think it would be a
devastating hit to microsoft that would
take a lot of effort and finances to
to to find an alternative solution to
not using the unreal engine
yeah i think you're probably right i
think they would use it in the meantime
though they don't have a problem giving
money to and microsoft probably has
solutions to something that like if that
ever happened too like for sure they
probably have something like in the
background but not nothing being done
because i'm pretty sure they have plan b
for a bunch of different things
travis before we before we head up out
of here i do have a question um
in regards to ue5 what game or what game
franchise are you looking uh forward to
seeing the most from uh using the uh ue
technology
you're gonna have to remind me some of
the ones that have announced they're
using it okay so youtube is using it
that looks really great coalition has it
uh coalition has it for gears for gears
i want to say remedy has it uh haven
studios with jay raymond
her team they got the studio
well no yeah yeah nobody know but but
they have it uh i hadn't had that list
earlier um but there it said like a ton
of dif just different like well i'm a
huge fan so that's that's huge
they've been they've been on epic for a
long time for obviously i actually felt
like years five was such a br i didn't
like gears 4 and i didn't really like
the original trilogy too much like i
thought they were okay games wow but
it's just like it was one of those
things where i could never fully play
one of those games you know what i'm
saying like i don't know i've never
liked the corridor shooting where you
clear a room you go to the next room i
feel like they did it very well but i
felt like gears 5 gave me the openness a
little bit that i didn't experience with
previous games and i know a lot of
people here's five is definitely like
the best one i'll agree with you there
but uh yeah i i i love all the years
games i just think they uh if you play
gears one like the year that came out
there was nothing like it it was such a
unique and like every it just did
everything right um so yeah i i think
probably just looking at the comments
people are posting things i'm going to
go with hellblade too i'm just i
actually really care about holds on that
game i think star field is important but
i think hellblade proves that the
original acquisitions they made has
going to have fruit to it
yeah that sounds good because star photo
makes a good game that's just but
doesn't make it a good game they've been
known to do that in the past
correct it doesn't prove anything about
microsoft stewardship of their company
but if they can if they can elevate
hellblade from one to this crazy thing
it's going to be it's going to be out of
worlds 2 is going to be key to that too
because that's
it i think what was it uh hellbla uh
outerworlds 2. outerworlds 2. i think
yeah uh
yeah that's true obsidian obsidian
although obsidian always makes good
games in my opinion i think they haven't
have a budget to those original studios
is going to be important because it's
showing that
microsoft intervening and buying these
studios actually helped those studios
and they didn't make the same type of
call quality product but you know i
appreciate every coming through man you
know we pretty much had the exact show
uh i i do apologize i need to start
being very vocal with the the eastern uh
pacific and central no because most of
the time we if you were to just put est
on 5 pm i would have you know what's
funny i usually put est in the in the in
the promo the promo stuff but i don't
know i was just i got i got off this
morning i made the promo i was so tired
i went to bed i didn't even think so i
just i looked at our twitter dms and i
was like did he tell me it was estee and
i just missed it and they no no that was
entirely right that was me i totally
forgot your east coast so you remember
anybody i talked to who's on iron lords
is uh
yeah we're all east coast you're always
killing it
you know
travis what what's outsourced you're
stealing pacific jobs here what what can
people find yet man you you and a lot of
podcasts lightly man like
i'm only in two weekly so i do a weekly
destiny podcast called the last word
which is on the show
which is on this channel it's uh on
thursdays uh at
uh 4 p.m pacific 7 p.m eastern
florida
the chosen
time the chosen timeline uh and then i
do
a show called big cast which is just
about the games industry in general uh
that show is with ainsley bowden who's
uh industry vet um richard hogue the the
lawyer i'm sure that's a very
interesting chemistry set it's a very
interesting and we get into debates me
and hogue we are we're very contentious
i uh i i get into arguments with him and
win i win against a lawyer because i'm
just that cool
all right
yeah so uh yeah you can watch that on
sunday mornings at 8am uh i think
there's a little bit of overlap with
your guys's show uh last the the um iron
lords podcast but uh yeah we uh we we do
that on sunday on sunday mornings um and
then also you can read all my stuff on
ign.com did a review of tiny tina's
recently a preview of a game at game
developer conference called uh super
fuse an upcoming uh diablo-like arpg um
and then i'm reviewing something else i
don't think i can talk about yet but i'm
hating that game uh so you can find all
my stuff on ign.com and follow me on
twitter at tigertravis if you if you
want to hear my hot takes and fast and
furious he's got a lot of hot takes
i don't know if he's got more hot text
you were whole i think it's pretty close
like i really do
it's huge
this guy i swear to god he says stuff
just because i feel like he always wants
to be on the other side like it doesn't
matter he does he does because i don't
say things because i'm contrarian i i
just i have opinions and i i just think
people don't think things through
sometimes but hogue is just like out
here slamming on all the things you love
and hating all and loving all the things
you hate it's weird man it's real weird
so
so what where can people find you hustle
i saw i saw the teenage mutant ninja
turtle couldn't really resonate with
much of any of it because i didn't
remember more games but you know what i
will say is i didn't know that game
wasn't going to be co like online
feature like
right there i pretty much dropped the
game mentally right there when i saw
that
well apparently four player online co-op
is a very hard thing to do if you play
scott pilgrim and i got to study on
scott pilgrim versus the world um
they they had trouble pulling that off
so it's the thing with four player co-op
that always seems to be an issue two
player co-op seems to be fine you can
find me at hustling motivate twitch
twitter and youtube but uh don't worry
about twitch so much because i can
really be there i'm working on my next
video um the last of us the last of us
will you know
my second favorite game of all time and
i can't wait to get into that one hey
travis before i go um the big case is
that the sg big ass yeah season gaming
that's what i thought that's what i
thought so i'm gonna make sure i listen
to you guys on itunes that's right
yeah that's fun if you uh if you like uh
hogue he uh
he gets to break down and sort of just
talk about other stuff that he doesn't
do on his channel which is really cool i
think we have a really unique show it's
uh it's different than other stuff you
see on youtube yeah hogue is an
extremely dope guy plus you know i know
you say he likes to argue a lot well he
is a lawyer right so i mean that's yes
and i was and i was pre-law and i'm a
jew so we just oh all the time it's just
it's just lots of arguing man that's
just all it is so well i look forward to
it you guys are on youtube as well
correct we are yeah yeah see i'll follow
you guys there too and that's how i know
it i'm not sure if you mentioned it but
i want to make sure that everybody else
knows it um thank you all for joining us
addict no once again you always put me
in the you always put me around the
legends man i really do appreciate
everything that you've done for me um
i'll be back sooner than you think um
the last of us video is coming up um
another turtles video is coming up when
the konami collection releases open the
cow bunga collection releases via konami
so i look forward to that you know i'm
about to really have some fun that i'm
about to really push for a thousand subs
this year on youtube yes sir i'm gonna
be playing that turtles game at pax this
year
just man don't rub it in my face
i'm gonna try to try to try to try to
get you a code man i'm gonna talk to the
devs try to get you a code
i appreciate it
yeah uh stratus revenge yeah nice
video i'll be like he makes content
everything right
let's get hustle code man let's i'm
gonna i'm gonna oprah
um they announced um in the i think it
was playstation's state of play i think
i'm not sure but they they showed the
trailer but and they showed some
gameplay but they didn't announce uh
they showed the year
of 2022 but they didn't announce a date
and they also showed the year for the uh
konami uh for the kyle bunga collection
which is 2022 but they haven't announced
today all right well i have a rule that
if they give me a year but not a date it
it's not coming out as far as i'm
concerned you know what i mean they've
got to give me that they at least have
to give me a month or it's 20 20.
especially
i'm a little bit more linger if it's
like spring 2022 or something like that
because i feel like they they picked the
beginning a little bit but if they say
holiday 2022 i'm like that's 20 20. oh
dude that's 20 23.
if they just say the year that's spring
sauce in my book that's like all right
dude you're probably coming out 2023 so
yeah i'll ask dan if i can review it
next year how about that
i look forward so i look forward to the
review let's go but yeah
and this is uh addicts you know we uh
definitely catch the iop this week let
me check and see if we have a guest i
obviously ain't gonna tell you to guess
because cognito would kill me uh if i
told you keeps it secret
we think you'd want to cross pollinate
on your other shows yeah but we like to
keep that like exclusive uh we are
having someone uh i don't know if he's
officially coming you know i'm not going
to say that uh because i don't know
because sometimes when we have certain
people from companies on we don't know
if they're coming on as like an official
part of that company that makes sense
like like sometimes there have been
people in the past like look i can come
on but i can't come on as a part of the
company and we can't really talk
anything about the company uh because
you know pr is sometimes especially
coming into like around this e3 kind of
timeline certain companies are very
strict on like interactions with
especially podcasts you guys don't
realize how hard it is to get some of
these companies like microsoft sony
nintendo to allow executives and people
like that to come on live
because they usually don't like live
they like pre-recorded where they can
check to make sure nothing crazy went
down
for sure but you know i appreciate every
coming through man you could definitely
uh follow all these people on twitter uh
you know i will put them in the
description below you can find me on
twitter too at lord addict iop we'll be
back next week uh i think i i have
another guest uh in mind i'm gonna tell
him eastern though uh definitely i'm
gonna tell him yeah yeah have me on
again and i'll be here for the whole
show
we'll definitely get you back on i mean
it was pretty much for the whole show we
were literally just just talked about
who we wanted to make games for like the
first 20 30 minutes of the show
but i appreciate it for coming through
man until next time this is gaming
addict hustle motivate and travis